هذا ما يبدو عليه الأمر عندما
يأكل 3500 شخص معًا
3500 شخصًا آخر ، وسيقدم معبد Shirdi
Sai Baba في ماهاراشترا
بالهند وجبة غداء لما لا يقل عن 40.000
شخص مجانًا ، وهذا يحدث كل
يوم 365 يومًا في السنة
[موسيقى
]  تم بناء المعبد في عام 2008 حول
فلسفة محددة من قبل الزعيم الروحي
ساي بابا بابا ، وهو ميثاق يأخذ بطاقة الهوية الصحيحة
قبل ليلة الكرنفال ، أي أن
بطاقة المرور تسمح باسمي أجاي ،
هذا هو الرجل المسؤول ميرا نام
سانجاي ليبس بانكن بار مرحبًا ميرا بلادي
براسادا أنا '  يقوم المشرف بالحالات الثانية
لكل منشفة يشرف على
المطبخ الضخم لأن هذا هو واحد من
أكبر المطابخ في آسيا حيث يبدأ اليوم في
الساعة 6:30 صباحًا
باستثناء بعض الزينة من تاريخنا Sigma
tinsel portal 2 منفردا حكايات النمر ما
لم أفعل  يعني أن رشاد الله أباد قام
بتثمين كتب أنني لم أضع ميزانية ولكن
ليس هناك وقت
بعض الناس يطبخون الخضار
شيئًا أوانيًا ، والبعض مسؤول
عن الخبز الذي تحصل عليه
كل يوم ، الوجبة مختلفة ولكن
النسبة هي نفسها دائمًا ،
نعم قد يأكل علي غذاء أخضر أو بطاقة على أر
نيكي sub J null chapati إذا لم تحصل على هذ
الأمر لصنع هذه الأطباق لـ 40.000 شخ
في اليوم ، فإ
الأمر يتطلب الكثير من الطعام ، وهنا ال
عداد 3.3 أطنان من  خبز 2 طن من
الخضار ما يقرب من طن واحد من العدس
ونصف طن من الحلوى الآن لصنع كل
هذا الطعام يتطلب المطبخ الكثير من
الطاقة في أسماك جنوب الصحراء التي صنعتها
مشروع OPA المرقّم
وهو سقف منفرد مغطى بألواح شمسية لذا
فهو  امسح مبادرات المعابد هذه
شيء يجب أن تفخر به
لكلب سانتوس الذي أفتقده كان احتمالًا
لك